déjà méricain dès que j'arrivais y avait
des personnes dans un bunker à main qui
déjà n'ont ils tiraient sur les
américains loïc 10 ans a fait un bond
dans le temps ce week end
allemands et américains face à face
comme il ya 75 ans en 1944 le parc de
diane est au coeur de la libération de
la ville
la 2e db en parallèle avec l'armée
américaine est venue au bois des claies
puisque sur les rapports américains on
peut lire le bois déclinant les
clayes-sous-bois sur la période du 24 au
26 août pour libérer cette partie de
l'île de france elle l'association
recréer l'histoire de cette division
créée en 1917 et qui débarquent en
normandie entre le 12 et le 14 juin
une reconstitution possible grâce à une
vingtaine de passionnés pour se souvenir
donc dans les charline avait une denrée
qui d'âge
on a encore une très bonne initiative et
j'arrive mais bon j'ai eu l'occasion de
voir quelques stands est très
intéressant ça fait rappeler des valeurs
à certaines personnes et puis ça fait
rappeler qu'elle est mais qui sont
battus pour nous défendre et que c'est
vraiment c'est bien de reconstituer tout
ça on n'imagine pas en fait tu n'arrives
pas se rendre compte que ça a pu exister
et que maintenant on vit tellement dans
une vie où on a quasiment tout tout nous
est donné on a peut-être tendance à
oublier qu'il ya des gens qui se sont
battus justement pour tout ça en fait
une période qui a laissé des traces dans
leur fuite les troupes allemandes
incendie le château pour ne laisser que
cette vue qui perdure encore aujourd'hui